WELCOME TO THE JULY SEVENTH
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING ADD THEIR
NOTING THE LACK OF A QUORUM
WILL GO AHEAD AND START AS
EIGHTY- SUBCOMMITTEE. SORRY I
WAS CALLED TO THE SELECT
COMMITTEE AT JUST TO REVIEW THE
RULES IF YOU'RE IN THE CHAMBERS
YOU HAVE TO WEAR A MASK IF
YOU'RE CALLING AND WE HAVE VERY
STRICT RULES- IF YOU'RE NOT IN
IDENTIFIED WITNESS THEN WE
SIMPLY WANT YOU TO STATE YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION THAT IS ALL THE
TESTIMONY WILL TAKE. IF YOU'RE-
LOOKING FOR A BILL THAT IS
BEING MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE WHERE IT PRESENTATION HAS
BEEN WAIVED AT THE END OF THE
COMMITTEE WILL ALLOW YOU TO
REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AND PUBLIC COMMENT-
WE GO QUICK. WE HAVE THIRTY
FOUR BILLS ARE. ON THE CALENDAR
TODAY AND AT SOME POINT WE WILL
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN-
I'M FILLING IN. FOR THE VACANCY
ON THE COMMITTEE. WITH THAT
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND START WITH
MISTER BRADFORD. SB SIX FIFTY
FIVE WHEN WE GET ENOUGH FOLKS
HERE AT ALL HAVE A TO PASS-
RECOMMENDATION. YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS IS
STRAIGHT FOR MEASURE X. SB SIX
FIVE FIVE SIMPLY- EXPANDS OUR
INSURANCE DIVERSITY. BY JUST
WORN A PARTIAL FROM A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR REPORTING
REQUIREMENT DOWN TO SEVENTY
FIVE HOPING TO CAPTURE ANOTHER
FIFTY BUSINESSES. AND I IN THAT
SPACE TO ALLOW US TO HAVE
BETTER. INFORMATION ON THE
AGGREGATE OF OUR DIVERSE
INSURANCE COMPANIES IN ORDER TO
HELP WITH SUPPLIER DIVERSITY
AND- THERE'S ANY AND IT'S NO
ADDITIONAL COST TO DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE TO DO SO. AND IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS MELISSA
GEAR- CHIEF DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT
INSURANCE HERE TO. ANSWER ANY
QUESTION I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU SO I
UNDERSTAND WHEN IT'S ON THE
PHONE BUT SHE'S HERE SIMPLY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS- WITH THAT
WE'LL JUST GO TO SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. ON. THE PHONE LINE
FOR SB SIX FIFTY FIVE. AND FOR
THOSE ON THE PHONE IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FROM SB.
SIX FIVE FIVE. THE MAN CARE
LONNIE FEW MOMENTS A NUMBER
COMMENTS COMING IN. OKAY THANK
YOU WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR MISTER BRADFORD
SEEN NONE WILL GO TO DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I THINK IT'S ON THE
VIDEO TODAY. YES NO YES WE ARE
GOOD MORNING CHAIR GONZALEZ.
GOOD MORNING I CAN'T SEE YOU
BUT I CAN HEAR YOU. YEAH YEAH
HI OKAY. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
CHAIR GNZALEZ VICE CHAIR
BIGELOW AND APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS
MILLION WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE HAVE NO FILE ON SB
SIX FIFTY FIVE THANK YOU MIKE
ALL RIGHT BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE I SEE NOBODY IN THE
CHAMBER SORRY FORGOT TO STATE
THAT- WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE MISTER BRADFORD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU AND SOON AS THERE IS
A QUORUM WE WILL TAKE THAT UP
THANK YOU. NEXXAR MISTER WHAT
KOWSKI. I DO HAVE A FARM NO I
DID NOT GET. WHAT WE DO AT. NOW
SECRETARY CAN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. GONZALEZ PRESENT BIGELOW
BRIAN CALDERON RIO CHAU DOLLY
DAVIE'S BORN GABRIEL. EDUARDO
GARCIA LIVING QUIRK YEAH
ROBERT RIVAS WEBER MULLIN
VACANCY. WITH THAT I'LL ACCEPT
A MOTION AYE MR BRADFORD'S BILL.
WE HAVE IT BY MISTER BIGELOW
SECOND PROMISE CARILLO AND THAT
GETS OUT A NUMBER A ROLL CALL
THANK YOU MISTER BRADFORD FOR
YOUR PATIENCE MR CASKEY A. B.
TWO SEVENTY FOUR ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION OF A MOTION
BY MISS KOREA AND THE SECOND
BY. DOCTOR CORK. WITH REGARD TO
THE FISCAL COSTS AND TWO
SEVENTY FOUR SAID AND ALICE'S
POINTS OUT IT'S ZERO THIS IS
SIMPLY ALLOW. LOCAL GOVERNMENT
TO SEND OUT PACKETS BY EMAIL
AND I WRITTEN ABOUT. THANK YOU
WILL GO AHEAD AND GO TO- THE
PHONE LINES IS THERE ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO IT SB
TWO SEVENTY FOUR. ONCE AGAIN
FOR THOSE PERSONS ON THE PHONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IN
OPPOSITION ORDER IN FAVOR OF
SB. TWO SEVEN FOUR. AND MANAGE
SHARE AND NO LINE COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU- THERE IS NOBODY IN
THE CHAMBERS WILL TAKE IT TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GIVE
A POSITION ON- S. B. TWO
SEVENTY FOUR. SHE STILL THERE.
OKAY MACHINE POPS UP AND TAKE
THAT IS NO POSITION WHEN I
GUESS THEY HAVE NO FILE AT IS
THERE ANYBODY AT. ALL HERE WE
GO. MILLIE. ALL RIGHT I SEE NO
QUESTION SIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE MISTER CASKEY HER TONIGHT
VOTE THANK YOU THAT GETS OUT ON
A ROLL CALL MR HEARD HIS FIRST
WEEK. FILE IN SB TWO SEVENTY
FOUR. OKAY DO WE KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH OKAY. PERHAPS WE
CAN GET THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
TO COME INTO THE BUILDING- THAT
MIGHT HELP RELIEVE US OF
TECHNICAL PROBLEMS THAT SEEM TO
HAPPEN LAST TWO WEEKS. MISTER
HERTZBERG YOU HAVE SB TWO
SEVENTY THREE ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A MOTION
BY DOCTOR QUIRK IN THE SECOND
BY MISTER CALDERON YOU MAY
BEGIN. BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
FACING THE BIGGEST DROUGHT THE
LAST FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
YEARS WE NEED TO DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE THIS ALLOWS FOR
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS BETWEEN
WATER AGENCIES. TO CAPTURE
STORMWATER US FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU- WE WILL. NOW GO TO
PHONE LINES ARE THERE ANYBODY
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO SB.
TWO SEVENTY THREE. AND WITH THE
FOUR PARTICIPANTS ARE IN FAVOR
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE.
THEN. ZERO AND MEDICARE- NO
COMMENTS COMMUNITY THANK YOU SO
MUCH WILL BRING IT BACK I SEE
NOBODY IN THE GALLERY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IF YOU'RE
THERE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR HE
IS SEVENTY THREE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
ESTIMATES THE BILL WILL RESULT
IN MINOR AND ABSORBABLE COSTS
FINANCE DOES NOT ANTICIPATE
THIS BILL TO CREATE A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE AS A
PROVIDES AUTHORITY FOR AN
OPTIONAL PROGRAM RATHER THAN
REQUIRE A NEW PROGRAM ORHIGHER
LEVEL OF SERVICE FROM LOCAL
AGENCIES. THANK YOU THANK YOU
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
I SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER EDWARD
THANK YOU CURRENTLY MANAGER
MEMBERS I WILL PLEASE THANK YOU
THANK YOU BACK IT'S OUT ON A
ROLL CALL IS MISSED LEYVA. HERE
ALL WE HAVE LEFT IS MISLAID HIS
BILLS AT THIS POINT- THE WILL
READ OUT THE BILLS THAT ARE
GOING ON CONSENT. SB SEVEN
SEVEN NINE BECKER SB FOUR ONE
ONE CORTES C. S. B. THREE THREE
THREE EGGMAN SB SEVENTY FOUR
GLAZER. SB TWO FIVE EIGHT
LAYERED SB TWO ONE NINE ACQUIRE
SB FOUR EIGHT ZERO STERN SB TWO
NINE TWO WILK SB SEVEN FIVE SIX
PUESTO. ACTORS THAT WITH
AMENDMENTS. SB SIX THREE FOUR.
COMMITTEE ON LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT SB EIGHT
ONE SEVEN COMEDIAN GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION SB EIGHT TO ONE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WATER. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION A CONTENT CALENDAR BY MR
BIGELOW SECOND BY MISS CARILLO-
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
AT THIS POINT WILL READ THE
BILLS THAT ARE MOVING TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. SB EIGHT THREE
ALLEN SB SIX EIGHT SIX GLAZER
S. B. TWO FOUR FIVE AND SALAS
AS BEASTS AT THREE NINE GROVE.
SB THREE NINE ZERO LAYERED SB
FOUR FOUR SEVEN LAYERED SB TWO
SEVEN EIGHT LEYVA. SB SEVEN
THREE SEVEN LIMON SB SIX SIX
ZERO NEWMAN S. B. TWO THREE TWO
NIELSEN. SB FORTY TWO PAN SB
SEVEN TWO RUBIO SB FIVE A ONE
ACCOUNT SKI S. B. YOU KNOW
SEVEN CASKEY. SB FIVE EIGHT
WILK SB EIGHT ONE FIVE
COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE SB
EIGHT TWO EIGHT COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION.
THANK YOU I REMIND PEOPLE THAT
IF THE COST OF BILLS OVER A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
IT GETS MOVED TO SUSPENSE OR IF
IT HAS A REPORT OR WORK GROUP
IN AT. I STILL DID NOT SEE-
SENATOR LEYVA AS. WE WILL GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ANY OF THE
BILLS THAT WERE MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE REGISTERING YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO ANY OF
THE BILLS MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE. OPERATOR. AND IF THEY ARE
IN OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO AND ONE
MOMENT PM SOMEONE COMMUNITY.
THANK. I'M ON PACE. AND FIRST
WILL WE WILL GO TO LINE AT
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBER
WILLIAM AT THE BURKE ON BEHALF
OF NEIGHBOR APPROACH WHAT
CALIFORNIA AND THE PRODUCT
SPONSOR AT EIGHT SB TWO FOUR
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE THE NUMBER TEN
ONE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
PRESENT THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION CONSCIENCE OF PORT
OF S. B. FOUR FOUR SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SOMEONE ONLINE
AT SIXTEEN ONE SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CALL QUERY WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU. NEXT ONE
LINE NUMBER NINETEEN ONE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS LINDSAY MCCONNELL AT
THE FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX EIGHT SIX THANK YOU
MR PRAYER WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
BREAK BECAUSE THE SENATOR DID
MAKE HER WAY INTO THE CHAMBERS
SO WE'RE GOING TO HEAR HER TO
BILLS AND I WILL GO BACK TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I NEED TO GET SENATE
EDUCATION STARTED. TURN IT OVER
TO MY VICE CHAIR GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE THANK YOU MISS MISS
LADY YOU HAVE- S. B. TWO NINETY
FOUR ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION OF EMOTION BY
MISS CARILLO. IN A SECOND BY DR
COURT YOU MAY PROCEED VERY GOOD
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS SB TWO NINETY FOUR
REMOVES THE TWELVE YOUR MAXIMUM
SERVICE CREDIT CAP. THEY CAN BE
EARNED BY AN EDUCATOR. TWO
NINETY FOUR SIMPLY REMOVES HIS
CAP TO ENSURE THE EDUCATORS
HAVE THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES AS
OTHER STATE EMPLOYEES. THIS
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND SEE IF THERE ARE ANY PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO SB TWO
NINETY FOUR. ON THE FUNDS. IN
GENERAL KAREN OPPOSITION ARE IN
FAVOR OF SB TWO NINE FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND
MADAM CHAIR NO COMMENTS COMING
IN AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
THERE'S NOBODY IN THE GALLERY
WILL GO TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ON SB TWO NINETY FOUR
DO YOU HAVE A FILE. MADAM CHAIR
OF FINANCE HAS NO POSITION ON
SB TWO NINETY FOUR. WE ESTIMATE
THE COSTS OF THIS BILL TO BE
MINOR AND ABSORB MOBILE AS THE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT LAW. AND
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT AW
REQUIRED EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS
TO REIMBURSE EMPLOYERS. FOR
RETIREMENT CONTRIBUTIONS PAID
TO AN EMPLOYEE DURING
COMPENSATED LEAVES OF ABSENCE.
TOP PERSON CASTERS HAVE NOT I
DON'T. OF THE FIVE SUBSTANTIVE
ADMINISTRATIVE OR
IMPLEMENTATION COSTS RELATED TO
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
TO HAVE ONE YEAH. YEAH CHECK IT
OUT ON. CHECK IT OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL WITH THAT MISS WEBER
NOT VOTING. THANK YOU. SB. FOUR
TEN. ALL RIGHT MISTER LEYVA IT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
I HAVE A MOTION BY MISS KOREA
SECOND BY DOCTOR CORK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MEMBERS SB FOUR TEN
INSURES THAT WORKER SAFETY IS
NEVER DELAYED OR SATISFIED AS A
RESULT OF DUPLICATIVE EXPENSIVE
OR UNNECESSARY ANALYSIS THE
ECONOMIC ASSESSMENT IS CALLED
THE STANDARDIZED REGIONAL
IMPACT ASSESSMENT ALSO KNOWN AS
THE SHARIA. WHEN IT COMES TO
WORKER SAFETY AND HEALTH
REFORMS WE'RE ALREADY AWARE OF
THE EXTENSIVE PROCESS THAT
EXISTS BEFORE RULE CAN BE
FINALIZED INCLUDING MULTIPLE
ADVISORY COMMITTEES THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURE ACT
PROCESS AND THE OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH STANDARDS
BOARD REVIEWS THE SCHREYER CAN
EXTEND THE RULE MAKING PROCESS
BY ONE TO TWO YEARS OR MORE AND
IN TURN CONTINUE TO ENDANGER
THE LIVES OF CALIFORNIANS AT
THEIR WORKPLACE. A FURTHER
DELAY IN ADOPTING SAFETY
STANDARDS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
APPROVED BY THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR AND I'VE ALREADY
GONE THROUGH MULTIPLE LEVELS OF
ADMINISTRATIVE AND FISCAL
REVIEW THIS MEANS THAT MANY
MORE WORKERS ARE AT A PRO
LONGED RISK OF SERIOUS INJURY
OR DEATH SIMPLY PUT SRI BRINGS
LITTLE TO THE WORKER SAFETY
RULE MAKING PROCESS OTHER THAN
GREATER DELAYS INFLATED STATE
COSTS AND MORE INJURIES
ILLNESSES. AND FATALITIES. AS
SUCH AS BEFORE EXEMPTS WORKER
SAFETY RULE MAKING FROM THE
REQUIREMENT FOR- FOR FORM A
SHARIA. ANY PROPOSED MAJOR
REGULATION SEVERAL STREET
AGENCIES STATE AGENCIES ALREADY
POSSESS- BENEFIT FROM THIS
EXEMPTION. SB FOUR TEN SIMPLY
ADDS ONE MORE. THIS CALL
REFLECTS THE EXCEPTIONALLY
DETAILED FISCAL ANALYSIS HAT
ALREADY OCCURS DURING CAL OSHA.
ADVISORY COMMITTEES AND ALLOWS
THE AGENCY TO FOCUS SCARCE
RESOURCES. IN MORE EFFECTIVE
WAYS MOST IMPORTANTLY THIS BILL
WOULD PROTECT THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF WORKERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. WITH ME IN SUPPORT
TODAY IS MISS MITCH STAGGER OF
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU AND I
WILL GO TO PHONE LINES- WITH
MITCH SNIDER. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS MITCH SNIDER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS BILL JUST
WANTED TO QUICKLY REITERATE THE
POINT REYES AND THEN OUR OFFICE
THAT THE BILL DOES SHAPE THE
STATE THE SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
TIME AND MONEY. YOU DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY HOW MUCH MONEY BUT
AFTER I HEARD SERIOUS COST IN
THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS SO- EVERY BILL
THAT THAT DOES HAVE A SURE
SORRY EVERY REGULATION THAT
DOES HAVE A SERIAL SAVE AT
LEAST THAT MUCH MONEY. WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND
WITH THAT WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES THOSE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF SB. FOUR TEN. AND
FOR THOSE PARTICIPANTS ON THE
PHONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO IF YOU'RE IN FAVOR
OPPOSITION OF S. B. FOUR ONE
ZERO. IN THE LONG LINE TWENTY
THREE TO THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ANDREA HAS FROM OPPOSED TO FOUR
ONE ZERO. THREE I'M AGAINST ALL
OF LAKELAND FELLS THANK YOU
THANK YOU WE ARE JUST GOING TO
TAKE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION YOUR OPINION. I
ARE SESSION NOT YOUR OPINION.
ANYMORE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO S. BEFORE. TEN
MENEM SHERA NO FURTHER COMMENTS
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU WITH THAT-
WE WILL SEE DOES DEPARTMENT
APPLY AND THERE'S NOBODY AND-
THERE IS SOMEBODY IN THE
CHAMBER THANK YOU I WOULD MISS
THAT. YOU MAY PROCEED. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE WEST ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT TO COME IN
FINANCE. FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE
A POSITION ON THIS BILL WE ARE
A PART OF THIS ROLE RELATIONS
DOES NOT ANTICIPATE ANY FISCAL
IMPACT AS A RESULT OF THIS BILL
AND THIS BILL COULD RESULT IN
REDUCED WORKLOAD FOR THE
DIVISION OF OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
AND HEALTH AND THE OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH STANDARDS
BOARD. ALL RIGHT- WE ARE GOING
TO BRING BACK MAYBE I SEE NO
QUESTIONS. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU THAT GETS
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL. WITH US
MISS WEBER NOT VOTING THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS.
I WANT TO GO BACK- TO STATE THE
RECORD THERE WAS LITTLE
CONFUSION SB TWO NINETY FOUR
DIG IT OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
WITH DOCTOR WEBER VOTING HI I.
MISS READ THE BILL ON WHICH SHE
WAS NOT VOTING SO I WANT THAT
FOR THE RECORD. NOW WILL GO
BACK TO PUBLIC COMMENT TO
FINISH UP ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO- A
BILL THAT WAS- ON SUSPENSE FILE
IN WAY PRESENTATION. AND ONCE
AGAIN THANK YOU HAVE A-
COMMENT. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN WILL NOT
ALIGN TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE. TWENTY THREE. MY
NAME IS ANDREA HAD STRONG AND I
AM OPPOSED TO. SB. SIX SIX ZERO
AND I'M ALSO OPPOSED TO. SB
EIGHTY THREE ALLEN. SB SEVEN
SEVEN NINE BACKER. SB SIX FIVE
FIVE BRADFORD. S. B. FOUR ONE
ONE CORTES C. SB THREE THREE
THREE EGGMAN SB SIX EIGHT SIX
GLAZER. SB SEVEN EIGHT FOUR
GLAZER. DEFINITELY S. B. TWO
FOUR FIVE GONZALEZ. SB. TWO
SEVEN THREE- SB SEVEN FIVE SIX
HUESO SB TWO FIVE EIGHT LAYERED
SB THREE NINE ZERO LAYERED SB
FOUR FOUR SEVEN LAYERED. THANKS
BE TO SEVEN EIGHT LEYVA SB TWO
NINE FOUR LEYVA. SB FOUR ONE
ZERO LEYVA SB SEVEN THREE SEVEN
WE LOAN SB TWO ONE NINE MCGUIRE.
DEFINITELY S. B. FOUR TWO TWO
PAN HI I JUST WANNA BE YOUR
LOVER HERE TO RUBIO. AT EIGHT
YEAH LEARN B. TWO ONE FOR WHITE.
I'M PLEASED OH ONE WHY COUNTIES
SB EIGHT. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
I WANNA BE CLEAR FOR PEOPLE-
YOU'RE NOT RECEIVING OPPOSITION
OR SUPPORT FOR ANY BILL THAT'S
ON THE AGENDA JUST THOSE THAT
WERE MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE.
WE'LL GO TO THE NEXT ONLINE.
AND THE ONLY ONE NUMBER
SEVENTEEN ONE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
DANIEL RODRIGUEZ CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA'S
GINNY COMMISSION INSTRUCT THE
PORT SB SEVEN SB SEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU. AND WE'LL GO
TO LINE AT FIFTEEN ONE FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MANY THIS ****
BASSMAN. I'M A RESIDENT OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I OPPOSE SB.
TWO FOUR FIVE. IN MANAGED CARE
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN
Q. THANK YOU I'M WITH THAT THAT
CONCLUDES OUR APPROPRIATIONS.
HEARING THANK YOU.